my next guest is a comedian whose new
album impregnated with wonder is
available now please welcome back the
very funny Pete Holmes thank you very
very much oh gosh it is it's wonderful
to be here I was uh was actually just in
New York here uh hail a cab just to stop
it from hitting you never know what to
tip those guys big week in my apartment
building this week very big week the the
phone book arrived yeah thank God I
don't know how he's getting by without
the phone book
open the door was staring up at me from
the floor like here we printed a portion
of the internet for you to throw away
so it's a lot of fun to tell jokes I'm
just so glad I'm not a magician are you
taking a moment today to be grateful
that you're not a magician
so much pressure County audiences come
out to have a good time magic is the
only kind of entertainment where 90% of
the crowd is trying to ruin it for
themselves go to a magic show just to
see if closed-minded threatened dudes
just like nope no way that impossible
mirror some sort of mirror you ain't saw
her in half yeah you didn't you proved
what none of us were trying to prove the
boy on stage is not actually a wizard
and it's always due to mirror no no I
girls are into it they're like there is
something more tell you should be that's
how I am I love magic
look at my friendly open face I sit in
the front row do I volunteer you're damn
right I volunteer a magician drops his
fake thumb I didn't see nothing
I want to believe I live in a non magic
world all day make it magic I was in a
show recently where I saw a man fly
listen to me
I didn't misspeak a man a wingless
mammal took flight
you're not thinking imagine if I flew
right now if I could figure out the
muscle in my butt that I need to flex oh
that's working and I just took off
I flew above the audience pick some of
you up with me we flew around best night
of our lives and I saw this and suddenly
I'm eight again and I'm filled with
majesty and the guy next to me I don't
know this guy who's this guy
leans over me and goes some magnet
magnet he can't fly Baghdad
first of all shut your mouth and enjoy
the show
second of all that explains nothing what
does that mean he stuffs his pocket with
magnets the stage is a magnet that was a
terrible I think those are just two
things he doesn't understand like I
don't get magnets and I don't get this
this is magnets one time I had two
pieces of metal they wouldn't touch then
I flipped one then they would that's how
he flies let's be very frustrating too
for the magician because there's no
noise to make when you see a magic trick
for the audience with comedy it's very
rewarding because there's a built-in
biological response which is laughter
but with magic there's nothing you can
see the best trick in the world whatever
noise you make sounds condescending and
fake it can be like okay Pete what was
your card you can tell me tell us now
what was your card it was the three of
clubs okay yeah and you signed it is
that right you signed it yeah okay then
you put it in this barrel of fire is
that correct we all watched as you
placed it in a barrel of fire yeah and
the whole time I was blindfolded upside
down and a tank of water is that correct
yeah it's back three o'clock and now
it's all on you and you just have to be
like
ah
now what I expected that was suck I mean
is the dream of every magician in the
world that there would be some sort of
involuntary knee-jerk response to seeing
magic that they would be like the tiger
was over here
voila it's over here and people just
like
you don't want to make this noise you
have to make this noise then there are
people they don't quite get the trick
but they fake it they're like oh yeah
no job
Oh The Tiger movie thank you very very
much everybody
Oh
all right could be right back